gentlemen we finally got to play the
division they had their sort of Ubisoft
out there closed beta for the division
over the past weekend allowing players
to finally get their hands on add this
sort of big apple shooter so now that
we've had some time with us what do we
think of the division we've sort of
we've had previews without iron coming
in and talking about it this weekend was
fun because everyone got to have a go
yeah and we've had bunches people in the
case of our community haven't go and
sort of talking about what they feel
about it and we're all having first of
all I think you probably play the most
out of the three of us here this weekend
possibly I think Eric maybe yeah just a
little over myself but uh you reach the
level cup I let it oh yeah reaches a
level cap would be eight in the dark
zone and then is a 12-12 in the dark
zone and then aid in the normal the
regular spot okay see I got this flip
that so for people who maybe don't know
who didn't get access to the beta what
did the beta consist our first of all
wrong it consisted of just one main
story mission you got like for the most
part just a sliver of the map that they
have um so that included like kind of
like random events you know like an
encounter uh only of the you know
there's three branches to like a your
tech your medic day you got just a
little fraction of kind of the single
player experience so it my opinion like
they set it up like it was kind of the
first mission you play and you kind of
go in and you're like oh here's your
here's your base I don't I gotta know if
away but yeah like here's your base in
here like the different areas which you
have to sort of essentially upgrade them
by upgrading them you got like new
abilities for your characters also get
upgrades yeah we did we just so everyone
knows we did start off at level four and
you do get a cut scene so we probably
didn't see the intro right okay so it's
hard to say I was wondering why because
it said you reach level five already
yeah wow I'm so good right so I'm want
to see what that is but yeah yeah and
I'd say the main concern of this over
closed beta was this dark zone right and
what the pvp PvE elements of it entail
and and trying to kind of like perfect
or you know just in general balance what
that what's going on what's going out
there and it weird let's talk about that
in a second so the dark zone
sort of this like instanced pvp arena
you kind of like ops to go into but the
general i guess moments moment gameplay
of the division Eric what is that for
people don't know and how did you have
what did you feel about um so basically
you we checked our way to the HQ where
you pretty much set up shop as Rob said
and then once you do that you do get
missions they're from different NPCs and
then you can venture out into the world
and then in the world there are a little
side mission side quests that you do you
know either literally I don't want to
say liberating an area but you kind of
clear out an area or in my case I think
I did one word you know you had to
activate a bunch of scanners um within
like a certain time limit and then that
would then give you experience for a
specific wing so it's like okay you just
got you know 400 experience points for
the medical wing and that'll like you
said allow you to upgrade stuff so there
was a couple of those I didn't most of
those for me other than the turning on
the scanners was mainly like clear these
guys out there they're bad dudes like
get rid of them and then like all right
good job would it get rid of them and
you sort of just wandering between like
alleyways like yeah walk blocks block
after block of some downtown Manhattan
I'm guessing totally this is being
played yeah yeah and you know
surprisingly for the amount that they
kind of like blocked off it was like a
third I'd say if maybe the total map who
knows mmm regardless i did a little more
of kind of like the side mission stuff
right and a couple of them actually
surprised me so you know yet off the bat
you have the alleys you have your city
but there are sewers there are all right
there was one that was actually really
surprisingly cool that I kind of stumble
onto was it was I think it was for like
the tech whatever tree it was to help
out it was like you know go down to a
water main and fix the water main
essentially and it was like get all the
lead pipes under yeah so like that and
it was like pretty cool I mean as far as
like it it just kind of opened up
another area where you basically
realized there's a lot going on with
this my guess is a large enjoyable they
could do with it right because like the
Madison Square Garden mission which is
the main the one that you sort of are
forced to do right the environmental
detail that area was actually kind of
good yeah but in saying that and maybe
like that's get to the first point that
I had going to have here which is about
had the game looks I was playing the
game
on my pc my pcs pretty good machine i
went into the options as basically
running as like if not super high then
ultra sure came does not look that great
like over yeah that's not good that same
play of that yeah I was like I'd say
passable began this is beta like I don't
know what are they holding but what are
they gonna do for like graphics wise i
don't know maybe there are like it rains
a little bit like someone's gonna come
in with an EMB and it's gonna look way
crazier but just in comparisons like the
anticipation that i have for this game
based off what they showed at e3 yeah
like some of the gameplay like i was
saying okay the shown the xbox version
so that's why it looks like muddy and
and the lighting super flat but even on
pc just i was kinda like oh really yeah
alright like for me it was like just a
witness I passable like yeah I thing to
witness at the same time and like that
game that's okay for nothing's happening
yeah it compared I yeah take a look at
that III video like it I think a lot of
the elements are there it's just really
toned back like you know you look at the
e3 video is like smoke coming out the
sewers I stuff and you catch that here
it is here yeah look at all like
gorgeous lighting and this is the e3
right yeah yeah i mean it's its present
its again toned back and like I take
quantity maybe even like I don't know it
could be that thing as well were they
whenever they show videos like this at
e3 they always shoot it like the magic
are like it's sunset and you're getting
this like real nice effect on me because
a lot of what's happening in the
Manhattan area were in was kind of like
very claustrophobic and snow storm ii
and oh yeah in any case it definitely
didn't didn't Wow yeah let's get on to
the next section I guess I want to talk
about briefly because we a lot of people
last weekend our last week when we
talked about the division we're asking
could you play this game solo and I
played it basically all the times I play
which wasn't much I was away this
weekend update' maybe four hours last
night essentially on my own and the
story seems super just blase in generic
in a way that like it's just so
disinterested yes or no so there were
there were like a couple of cool
elements that like took me away where he
again some of the side mission stuff
there was one that was um you kinda had
you what about kind of searching for
like on a hologram tapes of like the
events leading up to this warfare event
whatever was the you know about friday
black friday too many people went to
walmart and all went to [ __ ] i think
that's a pretty cool premise yeah like
perfect way to like anybody you know
they
the virus in the currency so it's like
everyone's using cash and it's [ __ ]
money's dirty dude Apple pay baby that's
the future but anyways there's one one
woman we're like it was like these
people getting stuck in a car you just
kind of like hearing it and not really
sick freeze-frame 3d hologram and it was
like these people in a car and they're
like I guess they were infected and
there's different factions right and one
the factions I guess they're all about
just wiping the slate clean urdu is
realized later and it was this crazy
graphic like audio log of these people
being burned alive in a car and it was
pretty heavy-duty like I mean I was kind
of like taking away but it was funny and
like how long it went on for this is I
like I get it yeah oh it was like it was
like I'd say a good like 34 so they were
able just screaming maybe you can help
me with something that sure who the [ __ ]
am i shooting in this game cuz I've seen
to be shooting just a lot of gangs yeah
yeah like poor people yeah but that's
gonna like how long has passed since the
event like months I'd say I'd say months
writing or silly it's just like a lot of
it like I'm shooting guys who look like
they're just like New York guys were
like Yankees caps on blowing them away
with my like federally purchased gone
just yeah nothing about it seems
particularly like whoosh is saving the
day I went yeah and from the single
player perspective like I'd like to see
more of like again there are supposedly
three factions but yeah I haven't really
found a way to distinguish them mmm like
what I don't know cleaners they got the
flan Thor so you know don't got that
shiner stairs on them and then I forget
what the main faction that we keep
swimming to Rikers Rikers or something
oh yeah so Aaron you know yes
unfortunately he's not here but he said
the Rikers actually uh they have pretty
good like story kind of moments are like
little little bits of audio logs and
stuff like that and they're a little bit
crazy and and whatnot we didn't get to
see them but um yeah if you want to talk
dark so you wanna talk to our zone yeah
yeah let's get into it I said the dark
zone is like the pvp area right you go
in and you can follow up with people and
join teams or you can go so long and
essentially like what are you what are
you doing in there Rob you're looking
for loop so there are there are late
kind of like hot zones for like PVE
stuff so you essentially you know you
you'd like or you should we'll get to
that later is you
be in a group and you go to these PvE
moments wreck shop get the loot you can
get up to six items of loot okay like
for you max out dark stone loot then you
have to go to extraction zone and
extract it now that is where the the
main rogue element comes in words like I
could kill you I go rogue I try to steal
your stuff and then extract it and
that's the only way to get the loot is
to extract it and then you basically
decontaminate it or ever so like it's
like a helicopter comes to like one
point it's like all right you got these
like it'll be here like 50 seconds yeah
it's like I'm gonna have and I had a
situation where i was running around on
my own and a bunch of guys would like
who dirty on there like voice comms to
me and I was like oh must be like steam
friends or like my name is just on your
dryer and statement and then they
followed me and then I was like doing a
bunch of stuff and then I walked into
her over there like put your [ __ ]
hands like what it was like surrender
now will murder you I was like I was
like frantically searching for the emos
to surrender and I didn't know how they
just they just shot me so what was it
like for you guys did you pile up in
groups and do that sort of stuff though
we did I for me at least I did both we
when we first played we played in a
group so it was me Rob Aaron and Jake
and that was a lot of fun it was you go
around you clear out these AI camps and
you get your loot and then we all go to
the evac spot and then we all kind of
post up the different spot you know like
hey guys make sure like you know if you
see anyone you know like call it out so
we can you know be ready in case these
guys want to turn on us or like maybe we
light them up and then we get the
helicopters like all right I'm going to
shoot the flare off ok cool the
helicopters here in like 10 seconds like
somebody ping so we can see if there's
threats and there's like no threats all
right everyone put their stuff on the on
the helicopter and then like later on
it's like all right let's just let's
just frickin go let's just go rogue yeah
and we're just running the streets
together and and that was a lot of fun I
think in that so that's like the key
point is like it is fun to go rogue on a
very innocent single-player do and just
rip him apart and yell and you get you
know it's like an aggressive it's fun
yeah however it went up and down I felt
like I played last Sunday which was
where I had the most sour experience but
when i was playing alone ones we this is
the big discussion it's like can you
play this game alone without getting
complete
manhandled by groups of four people or
more and you can and it happens a lot
and it's it'd be fine in my opinion if
it happened typically around these
extraction points right yeah but like
when I have my bad experience Sunday it
was anywhere i frickin when i'm getting
close you're saying you can't you say
like the zone on your own is like not
cool it's not i mean cuz i think by
sunday people people were teaming up and
figuring out how to go rogue how to you
know basically spots to hide out and
that's the thing is you also then you
get like the top level of rogue is like
manhunt where you're like a yellow icon
and everyone see you and the idea is
like you have a lot of laundry cool down
once you get that cool down Alloway you
level up a lot and you get a lot of
money and it's a good way to basically
get experience and money and people were
kind of exploiting that and that's
different story but um i'm getting at is
like it's just it's I wasn't having fun
I kind of dying I kept dying i can do it
i didn't even have loot on me i'm
probably okay when you like I guess at a
certain stage I can cater to everyone
right like it yeah are we just saying
that this is a game that you probably
are going to want to be playing with a
bunch of other people cuz a single payer
yourself didn't really feel that way so
you're single by yourself up like oh I
can do this yeah I mean there is there
is gonna be there is matchmaking so it's
not like right impossible to play with
other people and like you said you had
that proximity chat experience where
yeah fortunately on that it was like got
the wrong and it was pretty funny though
I know enjoy it yeah funny enough I just
quick story it's like I had the same
experience where some back some guy said
oh there's a dude here me uh he's got
loot should we kill him and I'm thinking
the whole time I can hear you why would
you even say that he's a haze running
away like alright anyways let's talk
about the sort of the main thing the
main crux of what this game is and that
I feel like Ubisoft in the past couple
of weeks have been very vocal about
saying hey this isn't the shooter this
is an RPG as if that's some sort of like
catch-all for hey guess what you can
have shooting that maybe doesn't have
the same feedback as a as a regular like
first person or third person shooter and
you know there are RPGs which have good
shooting in their own RPGs that have bad
shooting and what was the experience
like for you guys I guess first of all
you Erika somebody could play destiny a
lot which is essentially the same sort
of situation it just as I'm saying
couple weeks ago it's a little bit weird
we're using headshots
humans and a number of pops off usually
when you're doing it against like weird
you know crazy aliens doesn't have that
same sort of jarring effect how did you
feel about the shooting in the division
and could you see yourself enjoying his
hours and hours into the future sure uh
the shooting and the feedback actually
wasn't as bad as I thought it was going
to be I will say destiny on its own has
better like feedback that are feeling to
it that then in the division I guess
I've been suckered into that oh it's an
RPG so I don't really think about this
like the shootings passable and spine
like it's good enough mom and I want to
see kind of what it's like to use all
the skills and talents and all that
stuff maybe that changes the game who
knows but again you are doing shoeing
you are shooting a lot in that game mate
primarily so it is kind of weird to you
know hose down some of these guys for
800 800 800 800 and they don't die right
away like that's kind of weird unless
you have like a super high-powered
sniper rifle then it's kind of a little
bit more realistic where it's like oh I
hit him in the head and then I hit him
one more time and then he dies which is
still kind of not realistic right but at
least that's closer I thought that's how
i feel i don't know about how about you
rob yeah i'd like to think where I felt
frustrated was um we had the other day
just yesterday found a glitch were
essentially long story short I was
invisible to every place yeah yeah it
was really funny and bizarre as hell and
you did kind of feel wrong for doing it
but anyways I was killing people who
could not see me yeah however I mean
maybe I'm just pretty bad of your games
I don't know but it wasn't the case like
I was shotgunning these guys in the face
point-blank yeah like four times granted
maybe the shotgun was a little
underpowered yeah but I'd say for me it
was like a little spongy like that's
that's that's very much testing right
like I don't know and that seems to be
able want to look people are saying is
yeah so it I can't think of a game in
like a big triple a game in like the
past couple of years where so many
people didn't really know what it was
until I got to play it like it just
seemed like it was kind of all things to
all people and then we eventually played
in it's like oh that's what it is like
and it comes like four through a lot of
what people are saying in the comments
here as well big brothers have just said
my honest my issue honestly was lack of
open buildings like
it is a game that like you could say oh
if it's a game setting that happen that
means it's gonna be loads of places like
go and explore and that's kind of not
the case so it's I guess are you
satisfied by what you've seen in the
division does it take the boxes that you
had for what you wanted that game to be
wrong yeah I mean initially I was like
fairly satisfied i mean like i had a
drive just for this open beta to like
explore some more like again like I
found this water main area there's like
the sewer area there are yeah they're
not it there aren't enough but there are
open houses and like kind of rooms you
can go into there needs to be more of
that I totally agree but then again
that's kind of hopefully that's what
most of the map that they've blocked off
will have I don't know yeah maybe maybe
that interest does I'm because I'm
somebody who enjoys like exploring quite
a lot totally and it was kind of like
ticking the boxes in a little bit a
little bit yeah but maybe maybe just
quite not enough I what about you wreck
I somebody kind of very edged in why you
have to say because like I basically
wanted the chance wondering if this is
gonna take over your destiny um it will
a little bit at least in the in the
meantime because there's not much going
on in destiny right however I'm really
interested to see the rest of the single
player I the dark zone is a fun place
I'm kind curious is that the endgame is
that their endgame is there some like
higher level story stuff that we haven't
seen yet or is it just you know you play
to a certain point with these story
missions and side wishes and then dark
zone is your end game because if dark
zone is the endgame hypothetically I'm
kind of worried because yeah there are
gonna be people that love maybe love is
strong or like or love this single
player for what it is and enjoy that
part of the game but then after that
what's left for them the dark zone they
it's gonna be hard for people to play
single player in that regard but I'm
interested I cautiously yeah yeah okay
they go I think in a way like I'm kind
of not super hot on it but I I'm also i
think this was a game that the public
was willing to let it fail and I think
that it's kind of survived this beta
with actually with wood with a grander
sense of what this game is in the sort
of public in the gaming community and
I'm interested to hear what you guys
think they were watching and then
watching live or watching this on the
mound on gamespot our YouTube let us
know in a comment box below what do you
think of the division beta did you get
in
first of all and how long did you play
what do you think of what you played let
us know in the comment box below